je préviens tous mes amis reste de ma
famille jordi c'est ce soir que je fasse
on est la terre de la potinière avec
bouvard est donc juste avant notre
sketch osé un sketch avec tex et c'était
à l'époque des voitures qui parle qui
attend l'importunent la portière mal
fermée serrer la ceinture
ça a tellement gonflé tout le monde
qu'ils ont arrêté tout de suite nous
entre temps on a fait un sketch et axa
et bouvard on est en train de se
préparer un mois je suis lâché maquiller
je vais faire ma première télé au chaud
au petit théâtre de bouvard et bouvard
il dit mais lui a normalement il est
dans le moteur l'ordinateur mettez lui
une couverture on me mêle couverture m'a
jamais vu je viens à la fin du sketch et
le réalisateur il aurait pu y laisser le
temps qu'on retient la couverture rien
rien par une seconde de ma gueule
c'est alors qu'on me retire regardez le
pauvre jean marie on le voit pas dire
vous allez voir que tex 1 ça regarde les
dix jours plus tard se dérober et la
porte tiens à ta chérie ce genre de
sujet regardez ma de chevaux c'est
j'avais su à parce qu'on peut pas nier
d'un bon moi je dis toujours celle d'un
coup de ta gueule
[Musique]
jean-marie on abat sexe également